[موسيقى]
هنا في هونغ كونغ التقيت بواحدة من
مئات المدارس حول العالم
بمناسبة أول دعوة إلى الأرض في يوم
عمل للمساعدة في حماية البيئة ،
دعني أخبرك أن المجتمع هنا في
dsc international هم جميعًا في
الوالدين  طاقم المعلمين وطلاب السنة الثلاثة هذه
[تصفيق]
دعوتي إلى الأرض هي مستقبلنا وليس
فقط بالنسبة لنا ولكن بالنسبة لأولئك الذين سيأتون
بعدنا أيضًا ، كن لطيفًا مع الأرض
مثل الأرض لطيفة بالنسبة لنا ،
يمكن لشخص واحد إجراء تغيير
هنا  في المدرسة النهائية ، نربي
الجيل القادم من القادة ، سأستخدم
كمية أقل من البلاستيك يمكن أن ينقذ الحيتان
وأسود البحر ، فنحن ننقذ الأرض
خطوة واحدة في كل مرة
[موسيقى]
نعتقد أنه يمكننا جعل الأرض
أفضل  ضعها إذا
بدأنا التعلم في هذا العمر الأصغر
، فلنواجه الأمر ، فنحن
مستقبل العالم ، ولذا فإن أطفالنا
الصغار وأطفالهم وأطفالهم
وأطفالهم ونريدهم أن يتمتعوا بشبكة ويب لطيفة مثلما
فعلنا مع هؤلاء الأطفال من حولي  هم
حرفيا من جميع المشتركين  صغار العالم
يحاولون أيضًا المشاركة
والقيام بالمزيد لإحداث فرق من خلال
التجارب المباشرة
[تصفيق]
إنه يثير الفضول لمعرفة
ما يدور حولهم والأمل
هو أن يصبحوا في النهاية
مواطنين عالميين يمكنهم المشاركة  في الأسئلة الكبيرة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]